[Musique]
c'est à la salle intérieure je suis très
heureux de vous retrouver notre invité
principal ce soir c'est karl lagarfeld
karl lagarfeld bonsoir alors vous n'avez
plus votre éventail vous vous êtes
habitué à l'odeur de la france
d'actes mois et puis je veux dire une
chose les gens fument moins donc on est
plus exposé à tous alors en revanche
vous avez toujours vos lunettes de
soleil il fait si beau que ça autour de
vous car non mais vous avez les mets
tout seul et que c'est une chose de
politesse dans les verres teintés
embellissent tout le monde donc je
reconnaîtrais allait retirer puisque
tout le monde prend dix ans après les
tests les gardes puisque le monde est
plus jolie ainsi alors j'ai l'impression
de vos cheveux n'ont jamais été aussi
blanc car vous les faites bouillir ou
quoi non pas du tout pas du tout mes
cheveux sont de plus en plus blancs
parce que je met de plus en plus de
shampoing secte et klorane je m'excuse
de la publicité mais qui me pose la
question je réponds alors là bien sûr je
m'adresse à la marionnette parce que
carl vous dit qu'on jouait à la télé en
fait c'est ma marionnette qui va c'est
ce que les gens nous attendent de moi
c'est ça oui oui et puis j'ai parle
souvent à d'autres marionnettes voilà
alors qu'arles vous connaissez les
missions on perd nous serons tous les
deux nous parlerons de vous nous
parlerons de votre carrière de vos
succès de votre triomphe jusqu'au cola
light karl lagerfeld qui permet de faire
des ro karl lagerfeld
énorme grâce à ça on appelle rossi glé
alors on fait de mu accueilleront de
nouveau invité pour commenter avec nous
l'actualité de la semaine hervé morin le
ministre de la défense qui est un
spécialiste de la défense qui nous dira
par qui remplacer gallas
toujours en p2 nous recevrons eugène
saccomano pour son livre mes secrets du
foot chez plon gêne nous dira qu'il a
peur qu'après les candidats de la ferme
se fasse beaucoup de français qui passe
pour des cons en afrique du sud
en p3 après le zapping qui ont nous
accueillerons notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir férouz bendouiou pour l'
affaire des disparus de l'isère voilà
l'émission s'appelle
et
[Musique]
alors qu'arles vous êtes partout alors
autant être ici très heureux de vous
avoir ce soir vous sortez de l'elysée où
nicolas sarkozy vient de vous faire
commandeur de la légion d'honneur
un beagle
[Musique]
ça me semblait pas être décoré légion
d'honneur comme didier barbelivien et
daniela lumbroso qu'un non pas du tout
on m'avait dit en passant on ne pouvait
pas refuser et je me vois pas dire à
nicolas sarkozy aux côtés de monsieur
très gentil mais donc ça m'ouvre le
garder
mais ça aurait été une insulte à la
france absolument alors l'elysée dont
chanel bien sûr alors ils sont tellement
classe vos définitionnelle que
maintenant c'est pas les mannequins qui
défilent devant le public mais le public
qui défilent devant les mannequins
de la nouveauté il ya aussi le catalogue
des 3 suisses dont vous avez fait la
conception et les photos mais pas les
modèles c est amusant mais les 3 suisses
avec la crise sont plus que deux c'est
vrai oui
le cola on en a parlé vous avez dessiné
une collection de lunettes pour optic
2000 oui oui bah que vous savez c'est
une chose presque logique étant donné
que j'emporte tout le temps moi je
trouve que c'est très bien de d'avoir
beaucoup de contacts faire beaucoup de
choses et même pas pour gagner de
l'argent c'est parce qu'il faut rester
dans une mouvance d'aujourd'hui si on
fait le métier que je fais alors qu'est
ce que vous faites d'autres karl des
brosses à dents des non non mais c'est
pas contre les gens qui put la bouche
c'est pas très bon
alors vous dites je ne travaille pas
j'ai pas besoin de réfléchir c'est un
flash électronique et ça me prend plus
de temps de le mettre sur le banc greek
de là vers l'idée finalement dit oui
mais ça ne marche pas toujours et pas de
garantie mais j'ai la chance d'en voler
vision très défini tive peu avant le
réveil aussi pour les décors des défilés
et tout mais ça c'est une chance mais je
fais pas compter dessus votre pire idée
c'est quoi la plus mauvaise idée que
vous ayez jamais eu assez de savoir
faire pour tourner ça dans une bonne
idée
alors en revanche vous n'avez aucune
complaisance envers vous même vous dites
je suis auto fasciste car pour survivre
ils ne font rien se passer c'est aux
fêtes mots un peu durs pour une
discipline qui au fait à la fin ne me
coûte rien je me suis habitué à ça je
suis comme les animaux qu'ils mangent
que les plantes qui sont bons pour eux
qui touchent pas un rêve mais c'est
aussi simple que ça c'est une chose
d'instinct c'est très étrange alors vous
êtes une star mondiale un quart des dd
penthouse de new york aux hlm de
banlieue quand vous habitiez rue de
l'université il y avait des gens qui
faisaient vos poubelles oui mais la rue
du mas était maintenant c'est un palais
africains fais-moi l'arrêt aujourd'hui
vous êtes quai voltaire et quand vous
mettez devant votre fenêtre les japonais
vouent prennent en photo des japonais
depuis les bateaux mouches oui on peut
pas oui puis il annonce mon nom est
distinct la habite monsieur madame
chirac et karl lagerfeld je vais
déménager à cause de ça mais en même
temps c'est flatteur quelquefois je veux
dire mais vous savez je suis pas
victoria beckham
alors cette image cette marionnette
comme vous dites c'est votre armure vous
êtes très bavard mais en fait on sait
rien de vous vous dites la vérité je ne
veux pas la dire donc je suis obligé de
me taire je n'ai pas grand chose à dire
je n'ai pas à analyser les états d'âme
en public se trouve ça un public never
explain et la complète exact exact vous
dites on doit s'occuper de soi même en
fait ah oui parce que les laisser aller
c'est pas payant c'est mignon à 20-30
ans a pris donc occuper un peu tout ça
alors vous vivez seul et vous dites
quand elle résulte d'un choix la
solitude et le comble du luxe est vrai
qu est tout à fait parce que d'être
pauvres malades abandonnés et tout ça ça
doit être le comble de l'horreur ouais
mais si vous luttez pour avoir la paix
ça les courbes horrible mais c'est
malheureusement c'est comme ça c'est
heureux j'ai vu lire que la même chose
en même temps et tu sais que je
travaille beaucoup pour le métier que
j'aime le plus c'est à dire la mode la
photo est l'édition mais j'ai besoin
aussi de temps tout lire pour tous c'est
pas pour y faire étalage de sa chaussure
tous ces faits jamais les discours
intellectuel je vois les discussions
intellectuelles je n'aime qu'elle est
superficiel mais sanaa blij pas être con
à l'intérieur
alors
question sexe ses solos également vous
dites j'aime seulement les escortes haut
de gamme je n'aime pas couché avec les
gens que j'aime vraiment ça serait assez
la vérité dans l'absolu mais je vous dis
pas que la réalité c'est conforme à ses
phrases qui est plutôt une constatation
donc je ne suis pas obligé donner des
détails et des explications oui alors
pas beaucoup de sexe vous savez j'ai
commencé jeune oui vous en avez fait
beaucoup j'ai donné
la drogue j'ai vu beaucoup de monde en
prendre et ça leur a pas réussi je
préfère voir l'effet des drogues sur les
autres que sur moi j'admire les gens qui
ont dont d'autodestruction et je devrais
pas le dire mais je ne sais pas qui a
dit il est plus facile de savoir comment
se détruire que comment se sauver mais
moi malheureusement je suis pas doué
pour me perdre j'ai fait pour survivre
ouais et donc vous prenez pas de drogue
non j'ai pas besoin je suis déjà grisé
tout seul à les habiller comme ça jean
ils sont drôles
alors pas de vacances non plus pas de
vacances non j'ai fais un métier qui est
tellement soumis à des calendriers
bizarre que le mot vacances ne rentre
pas et puis pour la profession libérale
congé n'est pas payé
alors pas de restaurant gastronomique
non plus il ya longtemps que vous avez
compris que dans votre vie intérieure le
plus important c'était de rentrer dans
les 34 finalement
c'est pas de 34 ans et pas une ride
d'hommes mais je ne fais jamais des
vêtements essayé il faut tout leur
entrée dans les vêtements c'est pas les
vêtements qui doit mal et c'est moi qui
dois aller aux vêtements c'est comme une
discipline je ne pensais pas un vêtement
d'une taille ou du sud 48 je ne possède
pas alors vous avez une vie monacale une
vie monacale de luxe et voilà qu
allez-vous être croyant je vais très
croyant est ce que vous êtes riches
parce que vous êtes très très riche vous
savez les échelles de richesse sont
tellement d'efforts mais aujourd'hui que
c'est presque une coquetterie de dire
qu'on est pauvre par rapport à bill
gates par exemple goût de la vous
prendre la tête vous très pauvre
d'ailleurs non voulues et ça c'est
disproportionné mais ceci dit il fait un
très bon usage son argent monsieur oui
c'est donc il ya toute mon admiration
alors il ya un truc que je comprends pas
il paraît que vous avez 200 i-pod vous
savez pas qu'on peut mettre plusieurs
chansons sur un ippon
non non non ça j'ai déjà appris mais
vous savez mais ipod ont des références
derrière et c'est ce qui est dessus et
il ya à peu près une dizaine ou une
vingtaine de deux dvd car je les achète
ce fait mes choix et tout dessus sinon
ça m'embête à y rechercher c'est trop
long j'ai pas de temps alors en fait
vous êtes vous êtes débarrassé de
beaucoup de choses vite je déteste
posséder c'est vrai qu'à un moment de
votre vie vous êtes débarrassé de
plaintes
mieux qu'on puisse faire c'est il ya un
proverbe allemand qui dit
ni ma psy tunise dit adieu il récupérer
votre santé ouais ça fait longtemps que
je t'en parle j'adore faire les
collections parc de consoles vendues
conditions des choses mais après j'ai
pas envie de le posséder la seule chose
dont je me sépare pas c'est les livres
mais ça 300000 vous avez rêve tragique
savez je suis trilingue donc ça élargit
aussi l'éventail
alors vous dites ma vie est irréel dans
la mesure où j'ai tout fait pour
échapper à la réalité de la vie je me
suis fait ma réalité qui est en réalité
pour d'autres mais sa fonction pour les
gens de métier que je fais il faut le
genre de vie que je veux mais née il ya
presque pas de réalité dans votre
existence finalement il ya des réalités
on veut attraper un rhume sais pas j'ai
passé ma vie à vouloir éviter une
confrontation déplaisante avec une
réalité qui préfèrent ignorer c'est un
luxe vous regardez pas la télé vous
écoutez pas la radio vous n'aimez pas
les les voix étrangères qui envahissent
votre univers oui parce que tout est
dans ma tête et dans mon imagination je
n'aime pas le préfabriqué par d'autres
pour moi j'ai ma vision et je préfère
rester avait avec ça j'ai pas assez de
temps non plus parce que je dessine où
j'écris parce que je fais des facs
encore où j'écris des lettres parce que
ce téléphone peut je te dis jamais les
portables n'est rien parce qu'on dérange
les gens ne sait pas où on tombe moi je
fais porter mes lettres
on vous parlait toujours aussi vite en
fait c'est parce que votre mère vous
disais chaque jour tu as quatre minutes
pour me dire ce que tu as à me dire et
alors c'est toujours l'accent 1 quand
même oui j'ai une façon d'être en jeu
par les mains allemands aussi on me dit
un accent en anglais aussi je reconnais
que ma voix est étrange mais je peux pas
faire autrement avait appris le français
quand il est arrivé en france en allant
aussi braves en avant arrivé à 6 ans je
parlais anglais allemand français quand
même bon vocabulaire c'est à peine
élargie si vous voulez mais j'ai jamais
eu à à bûcher je pensais que vous aviez
appris le français en regardant la
septième compagnie au cinéma
non non d'ailleurs j'aurais pas compris
non non non non non non non je me
souviens même les premières choses qu'il
a pris en français les premiers poèmes
que j'ai appris en français ça c'est
commencer sur les adieux de marivent
tueur à la france quand elle était veuve
à 18 ans et qu'elle part en écosse et ça
commence en dieu pays chéri il reste que
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
karl lagerfeld
accueillant hervé morin
jeune sakho mado
alors vraiment un bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes ministre de la défense et même un
bon ministre défense la preuve c'est que
depuis que vous êtes la personne nous a
attaqués
et jean hopper alors vu sérieusement ça
consiste en quoi votre boulot à part
prêté des troupeaux américains quand ils
ont tant besoin
vous savez c'est d'abord une magnifique
responsabilités parce que vous êtes à la
tête d'une communauté absolument
extraordinaire qui est la communauté
militaire
dans les sociétés matérialistes comme
les nôtres on a une communauté qui porte
un certain nombre de valeurs de la
rigueur du devoir de du sens de la
mission
qu'ils sont en train de disparaître et
être responsable de cette communauté là
c'est d'abord
le bonheur d'être à la tête d'hommes et
de femmes
qui sont pas comme les autres voilà vous
avez combien il y en a trois cent vingt
mille alors vous trouvez pas ça un peu
sur avis d'essayer de rétablir l'ordre
en afghanistan alors qu'on n'arrive pas
à maintenir l'ordre dans les banlieues
françaises je trouve que m l'un en face
de l'autre c'est pas tout à fait exact
et rire
mais enfin oui c'est même totalement
malhonnête
mais ce que je sais au moins sur
l'afghanistan c'est que notre
responsabilité c'est d'être là bas en
afghanistan se joue une partie de la
sécurité du monde est ce qu'on peut
imaginer un seul instant que notre pays
qui est membre du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies qui est un des leaders
européens
puissent être absent d'un théâtre dans
lequel tous les pays européens sans
exception ils sont alors ya encore eu un
soldat français tué le 22 mai il
s'appelle christophe barek-deligny il
avait 38 ans marié deux jeunes enfants
vous dites quoi sa veuve j'ai rencontré
ça va bien entendu qui est elle-même
militaires médecins dans le même
régiment et qui sait que
quand on est militaire on fait un métier
qui n'est pas comme les autres et dont
on sait qu'il peut vous mener à la mort
au combat
et c'est quelque chose qui est
parfaitement assumée par la communauté
militaire et que même si bien entendu
c'est un malheur et qu'il ya deux
enfants qui sont sans père alors vous
êtes non seulement effectivement mises
la défense mais aussi président du
nouveau centre
le nouveau centre ce sont les centristes
qui ont rallié nicolas sarkozy entre les
deux tours de la présidentielle
donc comme vous voulez que votre parti
existe vous vous dites fonctions au 1er
tour le problème c'est que sarkozy n'est
pas d'accord pour votre candidat tirs il
a dit si tu persistes à de présenter je
te vire en septembre ça ce sont les
journaux qui dit cela
peut aussi vous garder si vous faites
les peluches et qui vous garde
les français doivent avoir un choix
parce que la société elle ne se résume
pas à des des modèles un parti à droite
et au centre et un candidat d'un côté et
un candidat de l'autre alors sarkozy il
a le choix il ya évidemment vous il peut
vous dire bon finalement résimont cher
hervé morin il peut convaincre berrou de
revenir vers la droite quand même sa
famille naturelle et puis à borloo parce
que borloo peut ratisser un peu dans les
centristes n'ont vous croyez pas écouté
tout ça c'est pas le moment de le
décider on verra ça à l'automne 2011
borloo quand il a su que sarkozy pensez
à lui il a dit ça s'arrose
alors je ne sais comme un heureux
bonsoir donc je suis ce soir pour parler
football avec karl lagerfel dont karl
décolleté
packard mais très bien il vient de
pouvait le portrait de plusieurs
footballeurs pour un journal de football
allemande dont un homme ça en fait je
suis comment j'y connais c'est quand
même à l'arrêt alors jeune nous animer
le lundi à 21h sur rtl on refait le
match ou en fait
ni fut lequan gêne parce que serrières
d'arracher votre truc quand même
au minéral
alors on fait le match que diffusé en
simultané sur i télé et nous publier mes
secrets du foot chez plon et c'est vrai
qu'à cinq jours du mondial on est
content de vous avoir avec nous
d'ailleurs vous avez sans doute le
portable de zidane on pourrait l'appeler
pour lui demander de venir dépanner non
la dernière fois ça a marché jusqu'à la
finale ouais alors dans votre ville
évidemment vous parler de domenech vous
dit grosso modo quoi c'est un mauvais
sélectionneur j'avais été tous les mois
quand une fois sur domenech je suis dit
comment la fédération qui est tellement
match hautement va chercher un type qui
va au cinéma qui ne délivre alors ça ça
m'avait profondément surpris mais
rapidement il s'est montré mauvais
sélectionneur et manager de l'équipe de
france eugène a par son incompétence à
suffisance son arrogance et ses sourcils
qu'est ce que vous lui reprochez
l'a déjà vous avez changé la bulle là je
lui reproche surtout moelleux
son comportement dans la communication
déjà ça c'est pas l'essentiel la limite
il ya des lip tordu ou ce type est
complètement dingue comme l'entraîneur
par exemple du bayern munich louis van
gaal
wahou et qui va en finale quand même de
la ligue des champions donc on peut rien
lui reprocher au plan du football
domenech ce qu'on lui reproche
essentiellement c'est au plan du
football il n'a jamais su donner du
style à l'équipe de france voilà on a le
sentiment d'avoir les meilleurs joueurs
de foot du monde et quand il joue en
jouant sous la direction de domenech
c'est une grande voix la demande
d'environnement de jouer ensemble au sur
les autres équipes sont dans le même cas
non mais vous dites il sait que plus
malin que le système médiatique et céret
qui se met en scène d'une façon
théâtrale nous reproche nous d'informer
déjà en draps pendaient des ragots il
n'a qu'à venir
et nous dire ce qu'il en est exactement
mais la vérité
mais vous lui tirez pont à des questions
par des questions il tutoie ses
interlocuteurs vitesse est assez
suffisant mais ça oui c'est ça c'est
sans son gros son gros défaut par
exemple quand vous êtes journaliste un
peu spécialisés et que quelques heures
avant le match où la veille d'un match
on lui dit mon vraiment comment cette
équipe va jouer et vous répond avec un
ballon sur une pelouse verte et il a ses
têtes serre qu'il a ses têtes ça c'est
terrible pour ces voix çà n'est à faire
si quelqu'un lui fait une réflexion il
le fait pas jouer quand même incroyable
ça c'est vrai actuellement il an'a après
benzema ben arfa ce qui fait qu eric
besson a dit qu'ils avaient passé
d'arabes dans l'équipe de france qui
extraordinaire quand même il faut lui
reconnaître une chose chez dumoulin qu
il n'est pas du tout raciste il n'a pas
pris ces trois joueurs pourquoi ils ont
toujours une valeur la wii bien sûr le
premier benzema parce qu'il a dit après
match au stade de france
je ne sais pas dans un match pas
écarter le deuxième nasri massages des
danses riz qui joue à arsenal qui fait
une rue une fin de saison formidable
tout nasri bas un jour et les
entraînements car et s'est assis à la
place de thierry henry un bon mais
beaucoup de
choses se tient 1-1 et enfin un peu fait
la guerre mon domaine et gravures et hop
fini et quant à ben arfa oui alors oui
la face c'est tout à fait différent ben
arfa il est venu diriger vers la fin il
est très sympa mais enfin il est venu à
des
rassemblements mais il n'a pas sauté au
cou domenech il a passé un coup des
anciens un résultat il n'a pas pris
alors que c'est un mozart du football il
rentre dans les 10 minutes à la fin d'un
match il peut vous mettre la panique
dans la défense adverse il a un talent
fou à l'écouté ils vont perdre ils vont
pas elles vont pas gagner la coupe du
monde ça c'est sûr en france et partir
quand même à certaines coupes du monde
très pessimiste
si finalement alors maintenant je ne
sais pas du tout la même chose avant les
gens ont certes toujours ça mais bon
c'est vrai mais oui c'est vrai dans les
résultats mais il faut savoir que la
dernière coupe du monde en 2006 les
trois premiers matches dans le groupe
comme ce que nous allons faire là on a
été catastrophique de la vie de tout le
monde et tout le monde à dire il faut
virer domenech viré cette équipe il y
avait des sondages dans l'équipe on se
souvient à 80% cette équipe est nulle et
nous avons nous assisté je m'entraîne
très bien à une équipe absolument
médiocre seulement à un moment donné il
ya zidane
sagnol vira et quelques anciens comme
c'était 4 5 ils ont mis mon on va faire
au croire au coach qu'on écoute on va
jouer en notre faveur ils jouent à leur
façon julien huitième film de finale
quart de finale demi finale et film et
voilà ça ne veut pas sur un produit non
parce qu'il ya plus de grands anciens il
ya plus une caste de d'anciens de type
il n'ya plus que jérémy sont tous gérés
en faisant alors là une équipe voilà qui
est pas sûr de gagner en acculant fait
qu'ils arrivent à faire trois passes de
suite dans l'équipe de france et zahia
on passe maintenant aux commentaires de
l'actualité de la semaine les plus
vitaux de blacko et c'est robert ménard
fondateur de reporters sans frontières
et présentateur de ménard sans interdit
sur i télé que nous retrouverons sur ce
plateau après le magnéto
[Musique]
on dira ce combat n'est tué neuf
personnes sur un bateau humanitaire est
vraiment pas très sympa et cette fois
les israéliens vont avoir du mal à se
faire passer pour des victimes
regrettent tout à l'heure tu as bien
fait tout son possible pour empêcher
c'est d'ailleurs la réprobation
internationale est unanime le secrétaire
général des nations unies sont choqués
la france condamnée la plupart des pays
l'union protesté protestations aussi à
moscou à pékin au brésil en amérique du
sud sans oublier l'organisation de
l'unité africaine qui dénonce un acte
brutal il hume et obama dans tout ça
basta lire contre les boulettes de
pétrole au large de la louisiane et les
l'aide d'israël au large de gaza il a
choisi son camp avant de critiquer
israël obama réclame une enquête
impartiale quel courage pourtant les
états unis savent depuis longtemps
comment sont traités les palestiniens en
2006 l'ex président américain jimmy
carter prix nobel de la paix 2002
déclarées la manière dont israël traite
les palestiniens est parfois pire que la
manière dont on traitait les noirs sous
l'apartheid en afrique du sud mais bon
obama lui le prix nobel de la paix il
s'en fout vu qu'il l'est déjà eu l'an
dernier tp
l'accord mise en image de julien gracq
voilà robert ménard bonsoir or
donc la sphère de la flottille de gaza
donc comme d'habitude la communauté
internationale s'est indignée elle
condamne elle trouve la réaction
d'israël disproportionnée enfin c'est
exactement ce qu'on a dit quand il ya eu
des frappes sur gaza l'opération plomb
fondu tout le monde y l'image d'israël
en a pris un coup enfin israël s'en
foutent son image apparemment non mais
surtout il s'en fout parce que ça sert à
rien de dire ça si on n'en tire pas les
conséquences
les conséquences étaient quoi c'est de
dire on va au moins faire une enquête
indépendante cei aura pas d' enquêtes
indépendantes y aura une enquête
impartiale or les gens pensent que c'est
que des mots c'est pas du tout des mots
l'anc est indépendante ça voulait dire
que c'était d'autre que les israéliens
que le gouvernement israélien qui ferait
cette enquête et là ça veut dire on
pense que le gouvernement israélien il
va enquêter sur ce qui vient de faire
c'est se [__] du monde c'est une
enquête qui pourrait être pourquoi pas
mené par un organisme international bien
entendu on verra comment ça se passe ça
ne sera pas facile mais vous pouvez pas
d'office condamné l'idée que l' enquête
n'aura pas lieu non attendez j'ai jamais
dit ça j'ai dit que vous n'avez pas
demandé une enquête internationale et
c'est pas pour rien et je vous signale
puisque vous êtes sur ce terrain là qui
a eu une réunion juste après du conseil
des droits de l'homme des nations unies
et que la france s'est abstenu quand on
a demandé une enquête internationale ça
veut dire il faut arrêter de prendre les
gens pour des imbéciles
vous n'avez pas envie alors mettre à dos
sur israël qu'est ce qui explique
l'impunité d'israël les états unis les
états unis parce que même si obama enfin
tu te souviens ce qu'il a dit à un
moment donné et comment il revient là
dessus il revient là dessus parce qu'il
ya un lobby pro israélien aux états unis
quoi il n'ya pas un lobby pro israël et
aux états unis ne sais pas si je vais
vous rêvez enfin il ya un lobby je ne
dis pas non là dessus je vois que deux
valeurs du tout comme ça avoir comme
seule explication celle ci c'est un peu
court et et pourquoi ils changent la vie
et pourquoi il fait parce qu'il ferait
avec n'importe quel autre pays quand on
est le président des états unis vous
avez une obligation de chercher les
voies et moyens pour
pour faire en sorte de ne pas aviver les
tensions et créer encore un peu plus la
version rigoler mais seul julien
j'attendais pour légaliser si vous avez
vu cette bonne méthode elle sert à gaz
unis ont engagé obama ont engagé ce
qu'on appelle les proximity talks est à
dire d un des pourparlers indirects
entre palestiniens et israéliens dans la
perspective d'un sommet international à
la fin de l'année qui permette enfin
d'essayer de régler cela et d'aboutir à
un processus de paix hillary clinton a
tout de même indiqué que la situation à
gaza n'était pas n'était pas soutenable
et qu'il fallait que et vous dit flight
l'échangé ça le tue moi je défends
l'état d'israël mais ces opérations là
maintenant et ça fait passer le hamas
pour des victimes en fait c'est fou feu
le hamas et des gens dangereux des gens
dangereux mais qui ont été élus
démocratiquement qu'est ce que vous
voulez y faire et au lieu de leur
enlever des moyens de pour l'heure pour
les légitimes et en faisant des choses
comme ça on leur donne aux tchétchènes
tapis rouge à hervé la question est
simple comment israël peut impunément
continuer à coloniser la palestine parce
que c'est ce qui se passe tous les jours
et les nouvelles maisons qui sont
construites et comment israël peut
maintenir son blocus sur gaza les
européens ont condamné le blocus depuis
sa création ou presque louis et les
européens ont un message particulier
apporté dans la question israélo
palestinienne
c'est que nous nous savons de notre
histoire que palestiniens et israéliens
ont un destin commun que quoi qu'il
arrive ils seront amenés à vivre
ensemble et donc 2 et a reconnu
dans sa durée bien un jour ou l'autre ça
finira par se faire mais même en europe
servez monde à se faire ça c'est ça
c'est un discours je sais bien que vous
êtes ministre vous pouvez difficilement
dire autre chose regardez je vous donner
un exemple très concret il ya tout un
tas de gens qui disent oui ces
humanitaires c'était des faux humanité
qu au milieu il est déjà vu les gens qui
détestent plus les juifs que la
politique israélienne je vous le concède
largement je suis pas naïf qu'est ce
qu'ils transportaient en particulier du
ciment pourquoi du ciment parce que si
l'on est interdite et individuelles au
recueil attendait quand les israéliens
disent mais pourquoi tous ces gens là
ils n'amènent pas le ciment dans notre
port on l'aurait amené mais dans le
monde arabe les gens qui vous disent
mais s'il se foutent du monde puisque le
ciment on peut pas le faire entrer
comment après avoir bombardé gaza comme
on a bombardé 1400 victimes des
centaines d'enfants répondent on peut
pas un trait entre introduire du ciment
parce que c'est pas humanitaire le
silence et se [__] du monde qu'un seul
contre arguments à ça c'est l'armement
nucléaire iranien et quand on entend par
une miss qui je ne veux pas que gaza
devienne un port iranien là qu'on se dit
ouais mais oui mais en même temps il
n'ya pas un de nos pays qui explique qui
dit explicitement il ya aussi un
problème de l'armé nucléaire en israël
non non il ya une différence notoire
entre israël et l'iran j'étais l'iran à
différents par ses dirigeants indiquent
que l' arme nucléaire notamment
pourraient servir à rayer de la carte
d'israël fait prenant quand même nous
dit ce lundi et non dimanche il ya quand
même une disparité par 600 personnes
aidées ça mais il faut dire aussi parce
que c'est ça qui alimente le deux poids
deux mesures l'idée dans cette partie du
monde confond on défend israël nous
malgré tout ce qu'on dit est que quand
c'est les arabes on leur tape dessus le
type dans la rue arabe qu'est ce qui
vous dit vous 10 mai et pourquoi vous
parlez pas de larmes aux yeux en israël
de l'armé nucléaire en israël pourquoi
vous en parlez pas on est bien placé la
france c'est nous qui les avons aidés au
début avoir l'âme nucléaire je dis pas
il faut il faut pas je dis il faut dire
tout il faut arrêter par rapport à
israël à d'avoir des prudences de
langage monsieur qu'on n'a pas par
rapport à un autre état que de toutes
les manières le problème se réglera dans
50 ou 100 ans lorsque la démographie
permettra dans une ville comme jérusalem
par exemple d'avoir une propension
d'arabes beaucoup plus importante que
nous proposons de juifs fut alors la
jeune saccomano et non 50 ans vous aurez
une solution qui fera que les
palestiniens vivent dans un état
démocratique et souverain et les
israéliens aussi au musée impose un
blocus quand je dis vous pouvez je dis
qu'il ya un jour une évidence s'impose
là et j'espère j'y vois là j'y crois
comme on a on a su construire un
continent de paix en europe après s'être
déchiré pendant des siècles que fait
notre fameuse ministre des affaires
étrangères l'anglais qu'on n'a pas vue
depuis sa nomination par les madame
ashton oui elle est nulle et mais non
seulement
des êtres en europe il faut ajouter que
ce prix elle ne fait rien si elle n'a
pas de pouvoir c'est à cause de nos
gouvernants une attitude par rapport à
l'europe eugène démagogique ça vient ça
vous le savez vous est pris au président
jean todt et une ministre affirme à ce
constat les français
tranquilles parce que ça l'est parce que
ça les arrangeait karl lagarfeld un mot
là-dessus est-ce qu'il faut pas remonter
beaucoup plus loin à la redistribution
des cartes cantona crise et d'état est
ce que c'était vraiment à faire comme ça
on 19e après la guerre de 48 à 148 oui
c'est ça c'est quand même un peu fait de
toutes pièces il ya eu la shoah on a
fait des choses c'est la chose quand on
a créé cet état on n'a pas pensé les
gens de l'époque ça pouvait voir et
m'ont avait trop mauvaise conscience on
sort d'un génocide dont on se dit qu'on
est responsable et on essaie de trouver
une solution c'est ça qui fait sauf que
on oublie c'est pas un peuple sans terre
qui arrive dans une terre sans peuple le
problème c'est que c'est un peuple sans
terre les israéliens mais c'est une
terre avec un peuple qui s'appelle les
palestiniens on les a oubliés dans cette
affaire-là des centaines de milliers de
palestiniens est aussi licencié il faut
il faut essayer d'être équilibrés et
apaisée sur ces questions voilà je pense
que c'est aussi notre responsabilité
de trouver et d'évoquer ces sujets là
avec la gravité et l'apaisement
nécessaire pour finir j'ai cité une
phrase de l'ibar navy ex ambassadeur
d'israël en france qui a dit la
politique de netanyahu risque
d'entraîner fin de l'état juif tel qu'il
a été rêvé et façonné par ses pères
fondateurs en transformant israël en un
ghetto surarmés elie barnavi mais c'est
une grande conscience on a affaire à un
pays à la fois dont on peut dire le mal
de la politique de son gouvernement mais
qui a des intellectuels brillantissime
qui a une presse indépendante et qui a
quelque chose d'incroyable c'est un
génie propre c'est une capacité de
s'analyser continuellement et de se
critiquer et ça c'est exceptionnel c'est
justement parce que le peuple juif a
subi ce qui l'a suivi c'est justement
parce que c'est une démocratie qu'on est
tellement exigeant par rapport à israël
si c'était dans un certain nombre
d'autres régimes on s'en foutrait là on
se dit non c'est pas possible qu'avec ce
qu'ils ont souffert avec l'intelligence
de ce peuple avec son histoire qu'ils
fassent ça tout à l'un des policiers
c'est pas possible bien robert ménard
merci d'avoir été avec nous donc on vous
retrouve du lundi au vendredi à 11
heures sur i télé merci beaucoup
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
karl lagerfeld
vivement un
eugène saccomano
mais mu accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir férouz
bendouiou bonsoir
alors faire au jeu le 8 juillet 1987
votre soeur chahrazed âgé de 10 ans
disparaît dans un sous sol de votre hlm
à bourgoin jallieu ni elle ni son corps
n'ont été retrouvés elle fait partie des
disparus de l'isère une affaire qui
vient à nouveau de faire la une avec la
destruction par la justice d'un certain
nombre de corps comme de vulgaires
scellé cette affaire nous en parlerons à
20 heures en attendant j'accueille
stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
à booster femmes pour la semaine de
guillon
[Musique]
eric besson regrette qu'il n'y ait aucun
joueur maghrébin en équipe de france
besson qui expulse des milliers de sans
papiers qui tout d'un coup s'inquiète du
sort de trois joueurs maghrébins c'est
un peu comme si le pdg de bp disait et
exagèrent en louisiane il pourrait faire
du tri sélectif
[Applaudissements]
dsk va déjeuner avec eric besson dans un
hôtel de montréal c'est drôle comme
association il y en a un qui a trahi son
parti et l'autre cas trahit sa femme
quoique besson a aussi trahi sa femme à
besson en trahison c'est le plus
béraud réorganise son parti c'est pas
difficile ils sont que deux
[Applaudissements]
martine aubry s'attire les foudres de la
droite après avoir comparé sarkozy à
bernard madoff
il ya une grande différence entre
sarkozy madoff made of nique les riches
alors que sarkozy et son bouclier fiscal
les protège
en tunisie les joueurs de l'équipe de
france ont joué sous le regard de leur
belle est ce qu'on peut voir les belles
en question
et non non non non les officiels pas les
exploits
voilà
un groupe d'experts estime que les
résultats de l'équipe d'angleterre au
mondial 2010 auront des conséquences
directes sur la bourse de londres [__]
[__] si les résultats de l'équipe de
france ont des conséquences sur la
bourse de paris vendée vendait tout tout
de suite
[Applaudissements]
regardez cette photo raymond domenech
s'entraîne à passer incognito
il est obligé en cas d'élimination de la
france dès le premier tour c'est une
question de survie ch
[Applaudissements]
le sinn chinoise de iphone touché par
une vague de suicides si vous achetez un
iphone soyez cohérents prenez un
abonnement chez france télécom
[Applaudissements]
le plus vieux godemichet du monde aurait
30 mille ans les paléontologues
recherche dorénavant la première femme
préhistorique à l'avoir utilisé
non pourquoi pourquoi vous mettez une
photo de régine jeudi trente mille ans
avant jésus-christ régine c'est après
c'est un président régine c'est après
jésus-christ
[Applaudissements]
un homme amputé des quatre membres va
traverser la manche je ne sais pas
comment il va faire je sais pas il va se
laisser entraîner par les courants
marins et se servir de son sexe comme
d'un gouvernail coûte un coup à droite
c'est pas
sans bras et sans jambes ils devraient
traverser les caraïbes ça ferait chier
les requins
est une exclusivité salut les terriens
thierry première photo de véronique
courjault en liberté le petit panier sur
le vélo pourrait servir à mettre une
glacière promener à futur bébé
[Applaudissements]
fabienne réclament au tribunal le sperme
de son mari décédé si jamais elle
obtient gain de cause qu'elle ne confie
pas son bébé à véronique courjault ne
jamais recongeler un produit qui a été
décongelé
laurence ferrari est enceinte céline
dion attend des jumeaux heureusement
heureusement laurie kit garou pas de
bébé en vue
après les scandales de pédophilie dans
l'église la banque du vatican est
soupçonné de blanchiment et un trafic de
cocaïne a été démantelé dans un couvent
de bonnes soeurs pédophilie drogue
blanchiment pour être un véritable état
mafieux il manque un assassinat on
attend la semaine prochaine salut à tous
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi
[Musique]
ferozkhel bonsoir le jour votre vie a
basculé vous aviez 11 ans et demi et
votre soeur chahrazed en avait 10 nous
sommes le 8 juillet 1987 à bourgoin
jallieu dans l'isère il est environ 13
heures chahrazed veut sortir jouer avec
ses copains mais votre mère ne la laisse
pas sortir seul sans vous sauf que vous
ce jour là vous êtes scotché devant les
programmes jeunesse de la télé
chahrazed insiste et votre mère finit
par céder à une condition c'est que
charazed descendent la poubelle
on retrouvera la poubelle mais pas
chahrazed
chahrazed ne remontent pas dans un
premier temps personne ne s'inquiète on
est des enfants on a envie de jouer
c'est les vacances scolaires donc non on
s'inquiète pas ce qui nous met la puce à
l'oreille en fait c'est un orage qui
aurait éclaté à peu près une heure et
demie après et comme consigne en fait
quand on était petits c'était de rentrer
des kebano rage pour se protéger bien
sûr et la voyant pas arriver ma mère
l'envoie chez les voisins pour deux
la récupérer en me disant c'est bon tu
veux rentrer quoi chez le voisin vous ne
pouvez pas vous décidez d'aller vérifier
à la piscine rien à ce moment là les
parents du quartier commence à être
prévenu tout le monde cherche tout le
monde s'inquiète on appelle la police et
la réaction incroyable de la police qui
qui vous dis arrêtez d'occuper les
lignes et arrêter de faire des blagues
au téléphone qui fait arrêter de jouer
avec le téléphone qui s'était pas rigolo
et qu'il y avait des choses plus
importantes à gérer la police finalement
n'arrivera qu'à 18h30 parce que ils ont
commencé à ressentir qu'en fait tout le
quartier commence à mobiliser alors là
les recherches commencent à s'organiser
sérieusement il ya des battus on fouille
les étangs et des chiens pisteurs qui
sont mis sur le coup beaucoup de moyens
mis en oeuvre mais aucun résultat aucun
témoignage
aucun signalement d'un individu suspect
rien tout le temps avançait plus la nuit
tombée et puis on s'inquiétait et à
partir de là tout le monde s'est mis
réellement à fouiller de partout
alors évidemment votre vie de famille à
l'époque et est bouleversée par cette
tragédie le vide laissé par l'absence de
charazed prend une place immense elle
devient une ombre dans cette famille
d'autant plus grande qu'elle est à bout
personne n'ose évoquer sa mort chez vous
à l'époque je crois que c'est pas une
question de tabou c'est plus une
question de de douleur qui était
tellement épaisse tellement lourde qui
occupait carrément tout l'espace on va
dire de la maison que peu de mots le
moindre remous concernant chahrazed
provoquer
un effondrement de l'âme énorme alors
vous grandissez dans ce silence dans
cette culpabilité évidemment on vous dit
pourquoi est-ce que je suis pas descendu
avec chahrazed ce jour là quoi we put
enfin d'un programme télévision qu'en
vacances en l'occurrence et depuis c'est
vrai qu'un qu'est ce qui se serait passé
si j'y étais allé à sa place si j'étais
allé avec elle
aujourd'hui vous vous dites qu à cette
époque vous auriez aimé avoir quelques
années de plus pour pouvoir tenir tête à
la police et la justice en effet ce qui
s'est passé ce qu'elle sans doute
aggraver la situation c'est que vos
parents sondés sont des immigrés il
parle pas bien français et l'enquète en
pâtit mes parents sont d'origine
algérienne sont arrivés en france très
jeune ils ont toujours travaillé et il
parle très mal et il le lisent pas du
tout donc du coup ils ont eu de mal à
s'exprimer a expliqué la situation et
c'est grave parce qu'à l'époque j'ai
vraiment senti qu'il y avait
un mépris visé par rapport à eux en fait
et du coup c'est vrai que je me suis dit
à cet âge là mais pourquoi je suis pas
plus vieille pourquoi moi je peux pas y
aller et taper du poing dix ans
maintenant des c'est pas parce qu'ils
comprennent pas qu'il faut les prendre
pour des imbéciles quoi c'est quand même
des êtres humains ils ont perdu
quelqu'un très important et il faut les
aider comme on est tout le monde aucun
soutien psychologique 1 la seule
personne que vous voyez à l'époque c'est
une assistante sociale la mer était très
contente lui ouvre la porte presque
lembras parce que tu sois enfin à
quelqu'un qui arrive et qui va m'aider
donc elle l'a fait rentrer la dame et
double oui je viens pour faire signer un
document dans ma mère très contente et
s'est dit ça y est on va leur prêter un
peu d'argent qu'on puisse au moins faire
mener les investigations
privées peut-être mais des
investigations qui pourraient les aider
à retrouver charade elle est là la dame
lui dit oui non mais attendez je vous
faire signer un document et le 10 mai
signée signé ma mère a dit ban qu'est ce
que c'est et là vous avez la sensation
qui dit bah en fait c'est pour arrêter
les allocations familiales 1 une semaine
après alors la famille est complètement
exclu de l' enquête par la police et
quand votre père au commissariat ils
disent carrément arrêter de nous
emmerder carrément on père est allé tous
les jours au commissariat pour essayer
de récupérer des informations pour
apporter des siennes parce qu'il a il a
cherché encore et encore il s'est arrêté
de travailler pour pouvoir
cherchez de partout seul en voiture il a
fait des kilomètres pas possible et
à chaque fois qu'il allait au
commissariat pour demander parce que
c'en était et ben au début on disait
qu'on allait leur appui râpé et vers la
fin sincèrement là carrément jetés ouais
on l'a dit c'est plus la peine de venir
plus désolé monsieur bendouiou vous ne
venez plus apte à rien vous avertira en
temps et en heure et alors quand votre
famille demande à voir le dossier vous
être envoyé sur grenoble ensuite de
grenoble à bourgoin de bourgoin lyon
enfin finalement vous êtes perdus devant
cette administration on n'a jamais su où
était le dossier de charazed on ne
savait pas du tout qu'ils sont occupés
on savait pas si c'était vers srpj de
lyon on savait pas si c'était le
commissariat on savait pas c'est la
gendarmerie et dès qu'on allait vers
l'un envers l'autre il nous renvoyait en
fait vers la haye vers l'autre 1 donc on
n'a jamais su alors en 2003 la sphère
rebondi quand vous apprenez que le
dossier de charazed est fermé depuis
1989 vous apprenez 15 ans après qu'en
fait dossier a été a été clos et
personne n'a averti la famille personne
j'ai commencé à voir la puce à l'oreille
en fait vers l'âge de 17 18 ans que je
devais passer mon permis de conduire et
je me suis rendu au commissariat de
bourgoin-jallieu justement parce que
j'avais besoin d'un autre jeune
documents et de là je rencontre
l'enquêteur qui s'est occupé du dossier
de ma soeur et en voyant il s'assoit
derrière son bureau et il me regarde il
fait vous avez retrouvé sur az
moi je me regarde comme ça je suis dit
mais attendez monsieur ça fait un petit
moment qu'on essaie de voler les
informations vous avais dit de ne plus
revenir à chaque fois que mon père est
venu vous l'avez jetez vous pouvez pas
maintenant c'est ça comme ça le dossier
d'encours en principe on recherche il me
dit ben moi je suis au courant de rien
voilà donc depuis 1989 chahrazed n'est
plus dans les fichiers des personnes
disparues mais ça veut dire que si un
corps d'enfant mort et retrouvé il n'y a
pas de possibilité de faire le lien n'y
a aucun lien possible parce que les
gendarmes ne sont pas informés et une
missive qui leur apparaît quand une
personne qui est porté disparu avec les
informations nécessaires la ce a pas été
le cas donc depuis 1989 jusqu'en 2003
elle n'a absolument jamais jamais été
inscrit sur le fichier des personnes
recherchées donc elle n'a jamais été
recherchées donc on l'a jamais trouvé
alors en 2005 d'être convoqué par le
procureur donc l'appareil vous vous
dites tiens il se passe peut-être un
truc voilà vous êtes excité vous y allez
est arrivé là bas devant le bureau en
fait il me regarde et me dit bon ben
voilà en fait je vais vous annoncer que
ont bouclé le dossier on a fini y a rien
d'intéressant on n'y a rien donc c'est
pas la peine et après ils me regardent
et puis me dit puis surtout surtout vous
évitez par la presse parce que je
comprends pas pourquoi vous avez écrit
mon nom comme ça il ya un daeu il n'a
pas je sais plus et voilà et donc là je
regarde comme ça complètement hébété
jeudi mais vous m'avez fait venir pour
ça
et là je suis reparti mais complètement
un
député rebelote on recommence alors vous
êtes très déterminés à vous commencez à
vous adresser aux médias vous créez un
site internet vous prenez enfin une
avocate ce qui effectivement d'un seul
coup simplifie beaucoup les choses et
vous obtenez la création d'une cellule
baptisée mineurs 38 donc qui est chargé
de retrouver ses neuf mineurs disparus
dans l'isère 38 c'est le nom de
départements d'isère il ya un numéro
vert qui est créée il ya une douzaine
d'enquêteurs qui sont mis sur le coup
parce que terrible c'est que le fait que
le numéro vert soit hors service vous
l'apprenez complètement par hasard était
lors d'une émission
radio café crennel voilà et donc on nous
demandait un peu d'expliquer de relater
les faits donc j'ai expliqué tout cas un
moment donné je fais mon appel à témoins
comme je le fais à chaque fois parce que
je me semble très important parce que
personne n'a la relance et ce fameux
numéro donc personne ne me connaît
personne ne peut nous renvoyer des
informations régulièrement dès que je
passe dans les médias je l' annonce est
là le monsieur m pas des nos coûts et là
il me dit non mais
madame bendouiou le numéro il n'est plus
activé depuis six semaines
et là je tombe des nues style mais c'est
impossible on n'est pas au courant
l'auteur de ces crimes est le même pour
tous ces neuf crimes c'est pour ça qu'on
a mélangé
pour justement essayer de voir si
c'était une seule personne qui avait
commis ces crimes ou si c'était
plusieurs voilà donc c'était
de trouver le maximum de renseignements
pour pouvoir faire des corrélations
possible entre les dossiers parce que
neuf fois se retrouver c'est quand même
beaucoup c'est trop oui une fois c'est
trop et puis voilà l affaire rebondit
une dernière fois donc lorsque la
justice détruit 11 corps considérés
comme des scellés comme de vulgaires
scellé ça c'est un rapport avec un
dossier qui instruit justement également
par le cabinet seban il concerne
mi-janvier qui est porté disparu depuis
1983 l'ue devait jamais n'a jamais pu
retrouver n'ont plus rien en 85 et des
ossements qui ont été découverts par des
spéléologues et on a demandé du fait de
la cdu dans 38 de faire des
rapprochements justement avec ludovic et
ses fameuses ossements et un moment
donné on nous a dit en fait
les ossements les a pas parce qu'ils ont
été détruits parce qu'en france on a le
droit au bout d'un certain temps quand
les dossiers sont clos de détruire des
cds et donc on a dit attention des
scellés même si les affaires sont
élucidées c'est dur pour nous de
l'accepter mais que l'on détruise des
corps parce qu'avant d'être des
ossements c'était quand même un corps
d'enfant je précise plus que les
ossements d'enfants mais oui les à son
enfant et de là en fait on a récupéré
une fameuse liste et dans cette liste il
y avait les ossements du vercors et
d'autres sont les d'autres autres lignes
vous aviez x femmes
retrouvez telle date détruit les décors
dont donc oui c'est ça voilà détruits et
s'allongent jusqu'à 11 voilà on cherche
à savoir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il faut dire
que hu michèle alliot marie s'est élevé
contre ça évidemment
michèle alliot marie a été la seule
personne humaine dans cette histoire en
fait en dix ans mais c'est pas possible
en france est illégal de détruire le
corps humain est ce que vous pensez que
votre soeur peut-être dans ces corps qui
ont été détenues sur ce que comme je les
dis plutôt elle n'a pas été recherché
depuis 89 jusqu'en 2003
alors aujourd'hui charazed disparue
depuis 23 ans pourquoi continuez vous le
combat féroce parce que je veux la
retrouver
je vous cache pas que
quand on lit tous ces dossiers
je n'imagine pas vivante
mais il faut dire aussi que ce sont
toutes des affaires qui ont été donnés
ici des et qu'en france aujourd'hui
peut-être s'ils sont pas décédées il ya
encore les assassins l'un qui sont en
train de se promener tranquillement et
c'est inacceptable
vous dites tant que charazed reposera
pas en paix je serai en guerre
tant qu'elle sera pas enterré dignement
je continuerai à me battre et je
continuerai à me battre également pour
toutes ces personnes parce que on oublie
dans cette histoire de scandale des
ossements qui ont été détruites et des
cadavres qui ont été détruits que la
question essentielle c'est se dire qui
sont ces douze personnes
vous arrivez à travailler à avoir une
vie normale à côté de ça
alors vos parents eux croient qu'un jour
chahrazed va frapper à la porte et les
serrer dans ses bras qu'ils y croient
toujours pour mes parents pour un grand
nombre de ma famille c'est très
difficile de
s'avouer probablement décédées pour eux
c'est plus rassurant de se dire bon on
va la retrouver elle va arriver avait
frappé à la porte et
mais vous voyez derrière ça il ya aussi
la question de
du conseil de l'assistance et de l'aide
aux victimes qui n'existent pas parce
que en fait on voit bien que
il ya des grandes carences en la matière
et ce dont on a besoin quand on est face
à une telle tragédie face à un tel drame
c'est qu'on puisse répondre à vos
questions bien merci de votre témoignage
dans tous les cafés rose c'est moi qui
vous remercie voilà c'était salut les
terriens avec un rien fait pendant
ensemble de sons
événement
eugène saccomano
tous ces plans robert ménard 11 heures
tous les jours sur i télé du lundi au
vendredi l'effet rouge ben milot merci
d'en bas
je remercie l'équipe qui m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission je vous laisse
avec les amis d'action discrète et
d'oeuvre hollande je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine et d'ici là sur
canalplus.fr salut les terriens
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
dinar du tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu